[Música]
bienvenidos y muchas gracias por
acompañarnos en esta entrevista
exclusiva entre el 11 y el 13 de
noviembre se llevó a cabo de manera
virtual la tercera edición del foro de
parís sobre la paz en este fin de año
pandémico tenemos el placer de recibir a
una de las participantes de este evento
de alto nivel la estadounidense melinda
gates copresidenta la fundación bill y
melinda gates que fundó en el 2000 con
su esposo el fundador de microsoft la
fundación es uno de los principales
actores privados en el frente
humanitario con 41 mil millones de
dólares invertidos en 20 años ambos se
comprometieron a destinar el 83 por
ciento de la fortuna a la fundación
melinda gates gracias por acompañarnos
hoy usted hizo un anuncio durante este
foro sobre la paz 70 millones de dólares
para luchar contra la pandemia de qué
manera
gracias por invitarme como fundación
decidimos hacer parte desde el comienzo
y de nuevo hoy en lo que se conoce como
el acelerador act el acceso a las
herramientas contra alcohol acelerado
invertimos hoy 70 millones de dólares de
manera adicional porque vemos la
efectividad que tendrá esa institución
global a través de la solidaridad para
que la vacuna llegue a todas las
personas y con precios accesibles parte
del dinero será para la distribución de
las vacunas y otra parte del dinero será
para continuar con las investigaciones
para otras nuevas vacunas que vendrán en
el futuro en el vaccines check and
online el programa mundial kóvacs que
está en parte administrado por la ms la
organización mundial de la salud tiene
como objetivo proveer 2 mil millones de
dosis a los países miembros incluyendo a
los países de bajos ingresos que podrían
recibirlas de manera gratuita oa precios
muy bajos si no se corre el riesgo de
vivir en un mundo según usted con dos
velocidades con los ricos por un lado y
por otro los no vacunados dejados al
margen
absolutamente sí por ejemplo esas dos
mil millones de dosis sólo se destinaron
a países de altos ingresos tendríamos el
doble de muertes en el mundo lo cual es
totalmente inaceptable inexacto pero si
esos dos mil millones de dosis se
dividen y algunas van a países de alto
ingreso algunas a los de medio y otras a
países de bajo ingreso podemos asegurar
que las primeras personas en recibir la
vacuna sean los trabajadores de la salud
en el mundo por ejemplo porque ellos son
quienes cuidan de los otros o también
podemos asegurarnos que la reciban los
trabajadores de la salud en primera
línea el 70% de los cuales son mujeres y
luego que la reciban las poblaciones
vulnerables es lo correcto para la salud
de las personas también es lo correcto
para nuestras economías si queremos
volver a poner en marcha el comercio
global tenemos que eliminar el kobe en
todas partes del mundo si no saltará de
un país a otro y nunca nos recuperaremos
del todo económicamente como planeta con
riesgo económico y pingüinos y de anatel
de hecho usted hizo un llamado para que
sí
ampliamente en una vacuna para todos y
la unión europea es un poco el líder en
materia de decir que no debe haber un
nacionalismo en la vacuna sino una buena
distribución para evitar que el virus se
mantenga en el mundo como usted me
explico no se mantiene en un cápsula de
expliqué
exactamente la unión europea y varios
otros países europeos han tomado este
papel de liderazgo junto con la web
meses se creó este acelerador acto
presidido por civil ramaphosa el
presidente de sudáfrica por la primera
ministra solberg de noruega y todo el
objetivo es asegurar que no haya
nacionalismo en la vacuna para que las
vacunas salgan inmediatamente para el
mundo entero
primero para los trabajadores de la
salud y luego lento pero seguro para las
poblaciones vulnerables y para todos los
demás si no hacemos eso estaremos en la
misma situación que vemos hoy por
ejemplo en australia y nueva zelanda
ellos han hecho un trabajo fenomenal
protegiendo a sus ciudadanos del cómic y
eliminándolo en sus países pero luego
ocurre la re importación cuando las
personas entran al país entonces en vez
de volver a abrir sus economías algo que
estaban empezando a hacer tienen que
cerrar algunos lugares colegios y
comercios la enfermedad seguirá saltando
por todas partes a menos de que nos
ocupemos de ella de una manera que
muestra
solidaridad y cooperación global y eso
es lo que este acelerador está haciendo
en la fundación gates gasta cada año
tres mil millones de dólares en salud
pública es más de lo que gastan muchos
estados y también más que la
organización mundial de la salud de la
cual la fundación se convirtió en el
principal contribuyente desde que donald
trump suspendió el financiamiento
estadounidense una decisión que de hecho
usted criticó que chequea
criticamos completamente la decisión de
la actual administración sobre salirse
de la oms durante una pandemia no se
deja de invertir en la institución que
se implementó para monitorear y ayudar
con las crisis sanitarias en el mundo
así cuando esta pandemia se acabe debió
haber una revisión general de los
lugares donde la o ms lo hizo
extraordinariamente bien y de los
lugares donde podría mejorarse pero
durante una pandemia uno no se sale
hemos trabajado con la ms durante más de
una década con drama para tratar de
atacar y erradicar el pollo para reducir
la viruela a nivel mundial sin lado ms
tendríamos muchas más muertes y mucha
más discapacidad en el mundo
piensa que el presidente electo joe
biden se reintegrará a lo ms que cambio
a nivel más global espera del electo
presidente para los estadounidenses y
tal vez también para los europeos
nuestra fundación bill y yo tenemos
mucha ilusión por trabajar por el
presidente electo bye y con la
vicepresidenta kamala harris es una
noticia fantástica que tengamos también
nuestra primera vicepresidenta mujer
afroamericana en eeuu
ellos ya conformaron un equipo de
trabajo frente al kobe 19 en eeuu han
aumentado la representación en el equipo
de trabajo frente al hobbit para que
haya diversos puntos de vista nosotros
conocemos a muchas muchas de las
personas que están en ese equipo de
trabajo realmente espero que se
reintegren a muchas de las alianzas
globales en el mundo ya lo están
señalando y saben que la única manera de
combatir esta pandemia es combatiendo la
para todo el mundo si vamos a
recuperarnos bien tenemos que
asegurarnos que haya una solidaridad
global en el mundo y realmente espero
por las conversaciones que bill y yo ya
hemos tenido con el presidente electo by
de que él los heros
en un lounge espectáculo y la baja el
anuncio que laboratorio pzifer realizó
sobre una cuna con 90 por ciento de
eficacia y que podría estar disponible a
partir de finales del año es una buena
noticia cree sin embargo que las
campañas de vacunación puedan empezar
sin que haya reticencia de algunas
personas que dudarían en dejarse vacunar
de personas que si te asfixia
y creo que son noticias absolutamente
excelentes para el mundo que la vacuna
pzifer parezca ser 90% eficaz es
fenomenal tienen que terminar su prueba
de fase 3 los reguladores verán los
datos para asegurarse que tiene
exactamente lo que se necesita para el
alto perfil de seguridad que se espera
pero parece que esa vacuna podría
empezar a ser manufacturada a finales de
este año lo que significa que en el
primer cuatrimestre de 2021 podríamos
empezar a ver su distribución y creo que
debería ser primero para los
trabajadores de la salud luego para las
poblaciones vulnerables luego para el
resto de la población a medida que la
vacuna se vaya extendiendo y que las
personas vean que muchos en su comunidad
se la están poniendo que es eficaz y las
personas pueden volver a la escuela y al
trabajo y realmente espero que algo de
esa duda y esa ansiedad sobre la vacuna
se reduzca y las personas digan bueno
acepte otras vacunas en mi cuerpo
esta es segura y voy a ponerme las
centrales para poder reintegrarme a la
sociedad y ayudar a construir la
economía muy bien
en su fundación y su marido bill gates
son objeto de múltiples teorías de tu
inspiración excéntrica se estarían
tratando de desarrollar vacunas para
despoblar esterilizar el mundo colonizar
áfrica producir tatuajes numéricos para
identificar a los portadores del coi 19
porque como explica semejante
conspiracionismo en torno a ustedes
mismos
y creo que es desconcertante cuando se
ven estas noticias falsas y esta
desinformación porque sabemos que eso le
costará su vida a las personas y eso es
profundamente desafortunado no sé de
dónde viene pero puedo decir que hay
mucha ansiedad en el mundo en este
momento por muy buenas razones la gente
está ansiosa gente está perdiendo su
trabajo tienen algún ser querido enfermo
creo que a veces cuando estamos ansiosos
tratamos de echarle la culpa al pero
cualquiera que conozca nuestra fundación
o vaya a nuestra página web sabrá que
durante más de 20 años
bill y yo hemos respaldado que cada vida
tiene el mismo valor creemos que sin
importar la comunidad en donde vivan las
personas deberían poder crecer para
tener una vida contenta y productiva por
eso nos involucramos desde el principio
en la ciencia de las basuras en asegurar
que existan terapias para el vih/sida
para que todo el mundo pueda tener una
vida sana y productiva eso es lo que
somos y realmente espero que las
personas que nos conocen y que empiezan
a entendernos como fundación vean que se
trata de eso
pero entiende de todas maneras que
algunas preocupaciones son porque su
fundación dispone de 48 mil millones de
dólares es comparable al pib de un
estado como lituania cuentan con 1500
colaboradores que identifican y conciben
los proyectos a veces se tiene la
impresión de que quieren reemplazar a
los estados para decidir las grandes
orientaciones de las inversiones
globales y eso evidentemente puede
asustar a los ciudadanos
y entiendo las preocupaciones y
escuchamos con atención esas
preocupaciones y críticas pero puedo
asegurarle no hay una sola cosa que
hagamos como fundación que no sea
transparente que no sea en asociación
con alguien más o que no sea revisada
por ejemplo este acelerador act o el
mecanismo de vacunas kóvacs fue
desarrollado por la comisión europea por
el presidente mayor en conjunto con
muchos otros líderes globales nosotros
sólo somos un participante de
financiación
y que asegura que se desarrolló buena
ciencia entiendo las preocupaciones pero
también creo que cuando las personas
entienden en cuántos proyectos estamos
involucrados en el mundo y que toda
nuestra misión es ayudar a las otras
personas a levantarse por sí mismas creo
que es posible empezar a entender cómo y
dónde actuamos
basta con mirar con quién trabajamos en
el mundo para entender quiénes somos
como pareja y como fundación
japonesa foundation
muchas gracias melinda gates por esta
entrevista gracias a ustedes por
habernos acompañado quédense en france
24 para más información
[Música]